chrissy teigen recently tweeted that
sheet the same thing for dinner every
night which is crazy i think she is
awesome she is super fun she's hilarious
she's great on Twitter she hosts lip
sync battle is a cookbook so I feel like
she knows what she's doing I want to see
what she's for dinner every night and I
also want to learn how to make it for
myself this morning I've decided I'm
gonna go out buy the ingredients make
her dinner and then have my co-workers
try it the meal is really simple it's a
full fish branzino cooked with garlic
olive oil rosemary and lemon
she actually has her mom cooking I think
I'm a pretty good cook I'm definitely
not a chef or a professional chef but
hey I could be chrissy teigen mom so I'm
in a fish market now and they have full
branzino tiers $75 I will say this is an
expensive thing to have every night but
if you're Christian you can afford it
and that's dope for her this might be a
special occasion thing for me but let's
go make some fish okay this is grossing
me out
it's bloody I've never cooked anything
like this before there's some eyeballs
and I'm gonna try to clean this oh god
it's so slimy else I'm just gonna cook
it the way she says she cooks it which
is covered with garlic and olive oil and
stuffed with lemon and roe
there it is yay once you get over the
slimy slippery like texture of that fish
it's totally fine
I'm excited I don't know who Chrissy
Teigen is I like crazy Egon I think
she's funny
amazing clap back consider what kind of
monster can eat the same thing for
dinner every night like it just seems
like something that only serial killers
do I think I could do it with a
cheeseburger mine will be ice cream
oh no oh what's fish no thanks
hard bath oh wow this looks good really
incredible discussing this is amazing
blown fish made this Wow well done Ally
I'm impressed people shouldn't be
weirded out by this I gave a sort of
fish looks like I get Mahara a lot I
love it no I'm all about the whole fish
yeah no I'm not gonna do this probably
that's nasty as hell
this smells awesome there's a little
bits of garlic and lemon is what
rosemary I hate you Alex
I meant to look mm-hmm very good I hate
that I could see its face it's
incredible his eyes here we put that
over time that actually helps right I
enjoy it I just don't know if I would
eat it every day but I love him I'll eat
this once a year if I'm dating someone
and we go to their parents house and I
pretend to be polite it's 1889 four
pounds
Wow Oh see though hundred dollars worth
official week goals I'm gonna go you
don't need me for this
you know what no I think we're gonna
stick with our initial mentality of
variety is the spice of life I wish I
could use this every day you don't know
how good she got it mmm bones I haven't
tried it yet so I'm gonna try it now mmm
oh it's so good I'm really happy I'm
gonna make this for dinner tonight
Wow